welcome to your mom's house
so we had this you know with the last
few weeks we played the the woman
lifting weights and screaming yeah and
then we had the woman getting the tattoo
and screaming yeah and now we have
laughing the left
Wow
dude I can't even wrap it here of you as
I came a rapper she's so weird
she's beard yeah and then we had do you
think she does that to psych out the
opponent yeah I'm sure it's wrong
no it's her thing you know yeah it works
oh yeah yeah yeah it definitely works
so the thing I'm looking for labeled
everything good the one called
everything okay so this is a man this
made me so happy
bloob and put together wait is this it
is it
what masterful work this is so good to
arm wrestlers the weightlifter and lady
getting the tattoo screaming all at the
same time it's good shit yeah
which one's your favorite so hi this
lady I hate and love the same I know
this one's great her face is great so
every day geeks I like the old lady in
the corner yeah the weightlifting now
it's all good man you can't you can't
really go wrong with this one